the biden administration's racial equity
ideology is rooted in a racist
lie the administration continues to
declare doom and gloom despite excellent
news on the vaccine front and
they continue to lie about the border
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressvpn.com
ben well we begin today with a with a a
weird story apparently
the biden's dog major has been involved
in another biting incident
is according to cnn and um it's funny
how they phrased this he's been involved
in another biting incident i mean
couldn't you say the dog bit somebody
like did biden bite the dog
he says the biden's dog major has been
involved
in another biting incident that required
medical attention two people with
knowledge of
the incident tell cnn so even when the
dog
just bites somebody the biden
administration is like well it was
involved in a biting incident might have
to cover this one up
apparently major biden is uh is a career
biting
criminal at this point meanwhile joe
biden's handlers continue
to ensure that he doesn't have to answer
any hard questions on anything yesterday
he was in the middle of some sort of
press session and
his handlers basically were just like
yeah we're not going to take any more
questions anymore
he's just sitting there all calm people
are shouting questions at him
the handlers are trying to rush people
out of the room yeah you got to stop
bothering grandpa
it's time for his meds it's time for
grandpa's meds okay he needs his time
this is the way that the united states
is now run the top levels
of american government are run by people
who are completely
non-transparent with you to the point
where they will not tell you a full
story about a dog biting people
remember it took like two weeks to find
out that major biden had actually bitten
someone before major biden was shipped
off to delaware now major biden is back
and eventually just starts biting people
again and we still don't know the full
story there meanwhile joe biden won't
answer any questions
okay all of this is just a mask for a
simple fact when it comes to the biden
administration
the biden administration is rooted in
dishonesty they're rooted in dishonesty
in that they are not transparent with
the american people but they are also
rooted in dishonesty because their
fundamental ideology is just a dishonest
ideology
there's a tweet that came out not from
the biden administration but is
indicative of how the biden
administration thinks about policy
we've talked about the equity ideology
of the biden administration before
they've said over and over and over
again that every element of this
administration
is going to be shot through with equity
and equity of course
is just a euphemism for racial
preference because the fact of the
matter is that equality
is about whether we all are being given
access
to individual rights protected by
government and pre-existing government
that is what equality is about equity is
about the idea that if two groups
have unequal outcomes this must be
because of some systemic prejudice this
must be
because of something in the system that
is bad and what this does is it removes
individual responsibility
if you live in a free system and you are
given
equal rights your rights are protected
by the government like you have the
right to life you have the right to
liberty
you have the right to keep and bear arms
you have the right to freedom of the
press and freedom of religion if all
those rights are protected
and then you end up unsuccessful in a
free country
then the baseline notion for most
rational people would be maybe your
personal actions had something to do
with your level of unsuccess
maybe your choices had something to do
with where you ended up but for the left
those choices don't matter at all
because you have to understand that in
marxist theory
virtually all human choices are shaped
by the systems in which we live
that's why marx suggested that all of
the problems in western society were
created by capitalism all we would have
to do
is shift the systems in which we live
and this would mold the brand new
humanity
in which everyone would be able to
succeed along the lines they saw fit
without regard to the kinds of choices
they were making they would simply stop
making bad choices because those bad
choices are the product of the system
now what this does is it removes
individual responsibility from people
now when you take this to the racial
sphere when you start suggesting
that people are not responsible for
their individual actions based on race
you sound like a white supremacist and
the fact is that much of the ideology of
vocaism much of the ideology of equity
sounds
exactly like the ideology of david duke
the idea that black people are incapable
of making
free and independent decisions and
therefore any
bad decision that is made by black
americans is to be attributed to the
system at large
this sounds like a removal of agency
from black people that is not only
inappropriate it is racist in and of
itself because
as it turns out black people are the
same as everyone
people of every other color we are all
capable of making individual decisions
and we are all responsible for the
individual decisions we make but the
left's equity ideology
is rooted in that fundamental lie which
is that certain types of people in
america are not responsible for their
personal decisions so
eugene goo who is this stanford trained
doctor
and of course was a big
push he was a big pusher of sort of cove
with lockdown very woke guy
he tweeted this out the other day and i
thought that this is this is so
indicative of how so much of the left
things because it is mainstream
left-wing thought at this point he
tweeted out black on asian crimes
only occur because of our system of
white supremacy that strips
african-americans of their economic
opportunities while taking respect and
dignity away from asian americans
also white people empower our experts at
dividing and conquering to stay in power
so presumably he was speaking about this
case that we discussed yesterday on the
program
in new york city where a man beat the
living hell
out of an asian woman on the street and
it turns out that this particular man
happened to be a black man and that
frankly is not supremely surprising in
new york city because as it turns out a
disproportionate number of people who
have been victimizing
asian american people are young black
people
so eugene goose solution to this his
explanation of this is that black people
have no agency black people are not
capable of making decisions
you see and because black people are not
all of america's structures must be
changed so as to
make all outcomes equivalent equal
rights
no longer matter we're going to have to
make decisions for you we're going to be
paternalistic we're going to make
decisions for you
so that your outcome is equivalent to
everybody else's outcome and if you do
something wrong
we're simply going to relieve you of the
responsibility this sounds like david
duke except in reverse right david duke
says that black people
have no agency because black people are
inferior the wokest say black people
inferior because white people have made
them inferior how about this black
people aren't inferior
how about black people are just the same
as every other other individuals in
american life
they're just as responsible for their
own individual decisions
they are just as capable of success they
are just as capable as it turns out of
not beating up
asian americans on the street and thus
if an individual person beats up an
asian american no matter the race that
person should be held fully responsible
for their level of hatred
and by the way his entire argument
eugene goo here that black on nation
crimes
only occur because of white supremacy is
utterly insane on its face it's crazy
it turns out that the man who was busted
now
for the attack on this asian american
woman is named brandon elliott he's 38
and as it turns out he was arrested in
2002 for the murder of his own mother in
the bronx
and then because of our idiotic criminal
justice system it turns out after after
you murder mommy you somehow get out on
parole i don't even know how that's
possible how do you murder your mother
and then we're like 17 years late well i
guess you know
it's been 17 years i mean and
i guess mom is gone for a while we'll
let him back up
within a year of him within a year and a
half of him getting out on parole
for having murdered his mother the guy
is beating up people on the street
what exactly does that have to do with
white supremacy exactly
the answer is it has nothing to do with
white supremacy but
none of that matters because people are
not responsible for their own decisions
so long
as they are of particular races in
america particularly victimized races
in america historically we'll get to
more of this in just one second because
this is the root lie that lies
at the heart of so much of the biden
administration ideology it is a racist
lie about black people being deprived of
agency it's the lie that
rob and d'angelo will tell you it's the
lie that abram x kenny will tell you it
is the lie that black people are somehow
inferior and incapable of making
personal decisions and it's idiotic it's
wrong it's disgusting and it's vicious
toward black americans
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first let us talk about the fact
that
april is right here and it means a lot
of not so fun things getting fooled
getting rained on getting your taxes
done
so if you need a positive experience to
balance all of that out continue
protecting your loved ones by getting
life insurance with policy genius
policy genius can help you compare top
insurers in one place say 50
or more on life insurance once you find
your best option the policy genius team
will set up your new policy for you and
answer any questions you have along the
way
and you can feel great knowing your
family has financial protection getting
started is super simple first
head on over to policygenius.com in
minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need you can compare quotes
to find your best price
since their licensed agents work for you
not the insurance company there's no
hassle
if you hit any speed bumps during the
application process policy genius will
take care of everything soup to nuts
that kind of service has earned policy
genius a five-star rating across
thousands of reviews
on trustpilot and google the best part
all the benefits of policy genius the
comparison tool the handling of
paperwork the unbiased advice
they are totally free to use policy
genius can promise that you won't leave
their website feeling like a fool
instead
say 50 or more about comparing life
insurance quotes feel good knowing if
something happens your loved ones will
be taken care of
super important stuff here if you're a
responsible human get life insurance
with my friends at policygenius.com go
to policygenius.com
to get started policy genius when it
comes to insurance it's nice and quite
important
to get it right okay so the lie
that certain people in america are
incapable of
personal decision making we're not
talking about people who have some sort
of actual disability we are talking
about simply based on your race you are
incapable of making a decision for which
you can be held responsible
this is now implicit in so much of
left-wing talking points
the most obvious place in which this is
is implicit it's not even implicit it's
almost explicit is the way the left will
talk about voting
so right now the left's case is that any
republican attempt
to create a regiment of voter id where
we can actually verify where you are
from
or to limit in some way early voting
this is somehow racist
the idea implicit here is that somehow
this is going to directly affect black
people specifically why are black people
incapable of getting a voter id that's
ridiculous
it's it's ridiculous are black people
incapable of voting on the day of
elections
of course not what exactly is racist
about seeking better voter verification
standards
and so the based on this original lie
what you will see piled up are more lies
right so the original lie
is that certain people in america are
not capable of making certain decisions
which is not true
and then rooted in that lie you'll see
lies about the policies that are being
promulgated
stacey abrams of course has been a big
proponent of the idea that massive voter
suppression is happening across the
country this is simply
not the case there is not massive voter
suppression it's amazing throughout 2020
we kept hearing
that donald trump was saying things that
were untrue about voting about voter
fraud and voter irregularity and i said
okay well he has to provide proof of
voter fraud and voter irregularity if we
are going to believe that
the media agreed okay but then the media
would say voter suppression is
widespread it's happening across the
country there is no evidence of
widespread voter suppression in the
united states
this is not a reality black americans
over represent
their percentage of the population in a
wide variety of swing states
when it comes to voting the the notion
that georgia was being victimized by
voter suppression is a lie
the notion that voter suppression was
taking place
in 2012 or 2016 or 2020 it's not true
but the media
pushed that narrative why because the
idea was that if they didn't get their
way it must be due to america's racist
systems it's always the racist system
that is depriving certain individuals of
choice even though in a free country
people are capable of the choice so you
see stacey abrams out there suggesting
that we're seeing an onslaught on voting
in this country
thanks to for example georgia law so
georgia's new law is not
it is not an onslaught on voting in this
country
georgia's new law is actually more lacks
on early voting than say new jersey
georgia's new law does not prevent
people from voting
it does not prevent people from drinking
water in line it does not prevent people
from being able to obtain a ballot it
doesn't do any of those things
and yet the argument from the left is
that it is designed to stop black people
from voting because somehow black people
are what incapable of jumping through
the
very basic hoop of getting an id i don't
think so here's stacey abrams pushing it
anyway
we deserve to have a say in the
direction of our nation
in the direction of our states and in
the direction of our communities
and when democracy is undermined by laws
that we have seen pass
not only in georgia but in iowa and laws
that are under consideration in arizona
in texas in new hampshire in florida
in 43 states across this country we are
seeing an
onslaught an attack on democracy that is
a lie it is not an attack on democracy
it is not an
onslaught these are very simple
verification procedures
and democrats want to undermine all of
those that's what the so-called for the
people act is all about this hr1
it is all about undermining voter
verification procedures
okay so recognize the actual agenda
which is to loosen voting procedures so
that
fraud actually becomes more common and
the possibility of fraud becomes more
common and ballot harvesting which i
think is one of the most nefarious
things in american voting
becomes the rule of the land that's the
actual goal but i'm but in order to push
that goal they're going to continue to
foster the lie
that these measures are aimed at
stopping black people from voting and or
black people are incapable of voting if
you put these conditions in place that
are equally applicable to everyone
how stupid are these lies they're so
stupid that even the washington post
which is a left-wing outlet
is now fact-checking these lies joe
biden suggested that the new georgia law
quote ends
voting hours early that it suppresses
voting he got four pinocchios for this
because it's not true okay on election
day in georgia polling places are open
from 7 a.m to 7 p.m
if you're in line by 7 pm you're allowed
to cast your ballot nothing in the new
law
changes those rules that didn't stop joe
biden from going out there and saying
that this
initiative is called un-american and
sick
he said quote deciding that you're going
to end voting at five o'clock when
working people are just
getting off work among the outrageous
parts of this new state law ends voting
hours early
okay none of this is true it is not true
university of georgia political sciences
charles bullock says you can criticize
the bill for many things i don't think
you can criticize it for reducing the
hours you can vote
so he's just telling things that are
openly untrue at this point
the washington post tries to make
excuses for biden
but it's a lie anyway and there's an
overall lie
okay the overall lie again is that these
voting verification laws are designed to
prevent black people from voting it is
not or that black people are incapable
of fulfilling these particular promises
this is not the case
but again this is the line we'll get
some more on that lie in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that if
you are a solid employer you're
constantly looking to upgrade your
employee base you are constantly looking
to make
your employment better and this is why
you need a zip recruiter there are a lot
of challenges
when it comes to finding the right
person for your role that's why hiring
can feel like trying to find a needle in
a haystack sure you can post your job to
some job board but then all you can do
is hope the right person comes along and
that's why you should try zip recruiter
for free
at dot com slash daily wire when you
post a job unzip recruiter gets sent to
out to over 100 top job sites with just
one click then
zip recruiter's matching technology
finds people with the right skills and
experience for your job and actively
invites them to apply
in fact zip recruit is so effective 4
out of five employers who post unzip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the very first day there's a reason we
here at the daily wire use
ziprecruiter.com to constantly make our
staff better it's no wonder over 2.3
million businesses
have come to zip recruiter for their
hiring needs so while other companies
overwhelm you with way too many
options ziprecruit will find you what
you're looking for at the needle in the
haystack
right now you can try zip recruiter for
free at this web address
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire once again remember to go to
this unique place ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e zip recruiter is
indeed
the smartest way to hire and go check
them out right now okay so how prevalent
are these lies about georgia's voting
laws for example they're so prevalent
that jamel hill who somehow continues to
fail up start off at espn lost her job
at espn
now she's over at the atlantic which is
supposed to be some sort of highfalutin
intellectual magazine which of course it
is not
she has a piece titled sports should
boycott georgia
so now because she doesn't like the law
in georgia
because it is quote unquote supposedly
racist this means that now
all sports should boycott georgia
and the politicization of everything
along along the basis of these lies
is pretty astonishing it truly is
and the the attempt to craft all of
american life around the lie
that laws that are equal in
applicability and do not victimize black
americans actively victimize black
americans because somehow black
americans are incapable of making basic
decisions
that lie is now being embedded in every
area of american life
it's being embedded in corporate life
it's being embedded in sports it's being
embedded in government it's being
embedded
in hollywood it's all embedded people
are not responsible for their own
decisions
because america is such a terrible
racist place so jamel hills
says that she now wants sports
organizations to boycott the state of
georgia she says in the past
major sports organizations have forced
other states to reconsider infringements
on their citizens rights
and that kind of pressure is sorely
needed in georgia now last week
georgia's republican governor brian kemp
signed an elections bill joe biden has
described as jim crow in the 21st
century which shows you what an insane
lie that is
jim crow explicitly created a separate
system of law for black americans and
treated them as inferior
there's nothing in the law like that
that is that's not only an overstatement
it's just an outright lie
but says jamel hill all of corporate
america should resonate to the lie
the law imposes new voter identification
requirements for absentee ballots well
clearly that's racist i mean you mean
you have to show
that you are who you say you are when
you vote absentee
if you can explain to me how that's
racist i'm willing to hear it
anyone dealer bueller it limits the use
of ballot drop boxes
oh you mean like ballot drop boxes where
people could just stuff the ballot box
or take ballots out of the ballot box
hmm it hands state officials more power
over local elections
even before the legislation passed many
voters of color in georgia faced hours
long queues at the polls by the way
voter suppression doesn't involve long
lines
any more than long lines with disneyland
are ride suppression
you know what voter suppression is voter
suppression is where you don't get to
vote
making those weights even more arduous
the new law bans giving food and water
to people in line vote that's not even
true
it bans giving any gift to people in
line when they are within 150 feet of
the polling place you can bring water
with you there are people outside who
can give you water this is just not true
okay so so again the the root lie here
is the one that is being pushed forward
that's being pushed forward in every
area of american life people are not
responsible for their own actions
whether we are talking criminal behavior
or whether we are talking about voting
law people are not responsible for their
own behavior so long
as we can continue to forward the
narrative that america is deeply racist
this is how you end up with new york
officials for example
talking about that asian-american woman
being beaten in new york city we've
already heard eugene goo blame that on
white supremacy here's a new york state
official
on asian american woman being beaten
saying this came from trump somehow this
is trump's fault
asian americans across the united states
have been sounding the alarm about hate
for years
these are not new attacks but the
incidents are unrelated
this came from trump that's my opinion
but it's been around
he used the world's largest bully for it
to spread
racism but he's not the only one
and every single assault that goes
unfettered
every time a door closes to a victim on
the ground
it emboldens these horrible people who
target
asian americans okay that would be the
that would be the borough president of
manhattan gail brewer blaming trump
for a a a murderer who got out on parole
beating up an asian-american woman
because people don't have any agency you
see
agency just does not exist there is no
agency
at all all of this is super ugly but
again so much of our politics is rooted
in lies and this is just another example
of politics rooted in lies by the way
more of this politics rooted in lies
when it comes to the the attempt to
paint america as racist
and thereby to say that all non-equal
outcome
is is due to america's white supremacy
you can see this in the shalvin trial
so the case that is currently being made
is that if derek shalvin is acquitted
on these murder charges that's because
of deep and abiding american racism
as we'll get to in a second that is just
not the case
it's just not the case we'll get to that
in one second first let us talk about
the fact
that if you are dealing with a medical
issue right now you really should go
get it taken care of now there are some
medical issues that people find super
embarrassing
i get it but if you can get it taken
care of discreetly and easily then why
would you not do so
with roman you get a free online
evaluation on ongoing care for erectile
dysfunction all from the comfort and
privacy of your home
a u.s licensed healthcare professional
will work with you to find the best
treatment plan
if medication is appropriate it ships to
you free with two day shipping the whole
process is straightforward and discreet
getting started is super simple just go
to getroman.com
complete an online visit today take care
of ed without leaving your home complete
that online visit today to connect with
a healthcare professional
and get it taken care of go to
getroman.com right now you'll get 15
bucks off your very first month
it's really time to take care of that
e.d again people tend to have medical
problems and particularly chronic
medical problems they think it'll go
away by itself it generally doesn't
very often they will think okay well you
know what it's too embarrassing to deal
with
why would you suffer with something when
you can get it done quickly and easily
with my friends over
at getroman.com and remember get started
today you save
15 bucks on your first order of ed
treatment that is getroman.com get 15
bucks off your very first month
it's time to take take care of your a.d
ed getroman.com
ben to get 15 bucks off your first order
of ed
treatment okay so the case that is that
is now
being made again is that everything in
america that we don't like is due to the
systemic racism of the united states and
is a data point in favor of the idea
that america is systemically racist
the latest case that's being used on
this basis of course is the derek
chalvin case
this is why you see van jones making the
case that if there is no conviction
it is open season for cops dan jones
says that that if we don't convict derek
calvin
then cops will be able to get away with
murder in broad daylight
no that is not what that means that is
not what that means you see jonathan
capehart
saying the exact same thing jonathan k
part of the washington post here he is
making the case
that he is ready for not guilty because
america is racist not because of the
details of the case we don't need the
details of the case
that's irrelevant he's ready for not
guilty because of america's history
everything is just evidence of american
racism i
am already prepared for
a not guilty verdict and i i and i
you know i hesitate to say that but just
given
given the history of this country in the
history of these situations
i have to ema intellectually and
emotionally prepare myself for that
okay meanwhile chelsea handler again
another member of the left she says we
shouldn't even have trials
in cases like this one right the
narrative is so strong
you don't even need a trial due process
goes away so chelsea handler genius that
she is she tweeted out so pathetic that
there is a trial to prove that derrick
shalom killed george floyd when there is
video of him doing so
oh that makes sense we shouldn't have
trials anymore
no more due process we'll just go
straight to the conviction because after
all
who needs due process when you have the
narrative now here's the realities i've
mentioned about this case
this is a heavy lift for prosecution and
this is not an easy case for the
prosecution and she
was double down on that by the way she
said perhaps we skip trials when there
is audio and video footage of the murder
but
there are several issues that still have
to be adjudicated here okay so for
example
the prosecution has to show beyond a
reasonable doubt not by
preponderance of the evidence beyond a
reasonable doubt that floyd's death was
caused by derek shavin's actions
but the autopsy report shows that floyd
was high on fentanyl and meth at the
time and had a serious heart problem
and shows that chalvin's neck hold
didn't in fact cause damage to floyd's
trachea which means he didn't damage his
airway
which means that while shelving's neck
restraint could have contributed to
floyd's death by ratcheting up his blood
pressure for example
it's uncertain that it caused floyd's
death more than say the arrest in the
first place the excited delirium that
floor was
that floyd was pretty obviously in
before he was even on the ground
that's before you even get to the
charges right that's just the basic
causation issue in order to charge him
with manslaughter or murder you have to
show that his actions led to floyd's
death
okay and it can't just be but for
causation right but for shalvin
being there doing that he would have
lived it has to be that his actions
actually cause the death
there's a pretty strong medical case
that that may not in fact be the case
in a second i'm going to explain the
actual charges okay again
the narrative here is that america is
racist that anything that we don't like
is due to american racism
and this is just another example of that
okay but there are very specific
questions that are asked in court
on these sorts of issues so let's talk
about the charges for a moment
there are three charges that are being
brought against derrick shalvin one
second-degree murder
two third degree murder and three
second-degree manslaughter
second dream second degree murder is a
is a fairly heavy lift it requires that
the prosecution prove
beyond a reasonable doubt that chalvin
unintentionally killed floyd while
intentionally committing a felony
so the question is did he intentionally
commit a felony did he believe
that he was committing felony assault on
george floyd when he was
holding him in a minneapolis police
department approved neckhole by the way
for eight minutes and 46 seconds well a
crowd of ongoers
uh onlookers was yelling at him now
again it's not just
do you believe that that's true or not
the question is do you believe it beyond
a reasonable doubt
reasonable doubt is a very high standard
of proof
so a jury could easily find that this is
not beyond a reasonable doubt
felony assault requires intentional
infliction of bodily harm that chalvin
wanted to hurt floyd
not just use a suppression tactic that's
already been greenlit by the minneapolis
police department
is there evidence that he actively
wanted to hurt floyd there or is there
evidence that he was negligent
he'll get to negligence in a second
because that brings us to manslaughter
case
third degree murder depraved heart
murder that one
doesn't really seem to hold because
depraved murder the legal definition
requires that you acted in a way quote
eminently dangerous to others
others plural so usually depraved
murderer is a drug dealer distributing
drugs
that are tainted in some way such that
they will kill people
and you distribute them to a number of
people and you know somebody's gonna die
you didn't have specific intent to kill
one direct person
but you knew that there was a good shot
that somebody was going to die you fire
a gun into a crowd you drop a brick off
a freeway overpass onto the cars below
right that sort of stuff is depraved
heart murder
this has a specific alleged victim and
that means that you are really not
looking at a depraved
murder so third degree really shouldn't
even apply in fact a higher court at one
point
had thrown actually the trial court
originally throughout the third degree
murder charge and then it was reinstated
by a higher court and finally their
second degree manslaughter and this is
the one
that is most likely that chapman is
convicted on but if he's convicted of
manslaughter and not of murder do you
think jonathan k part is going to
reevaluate
his belief in the racism of the american
system i don't by the way even if even
if chavan is convicted do you think
jonathan k part and van jones are going
to reevaluate their beliefs about the
racism of the american system
of course not because it is a premise
that must never be challenged
the racism of the american system
because so long as there is disparate
outcome
it must be the system and here's the
thing there will always be desperate
outcomes so long as people make
disparate actions
and so that second degree manslaughter
charge in the shouting case it requires
the prosecution prove
that chavin acted with gross negligence
but
gross negligence would have to show that
sheldon should have known his behavior
might cause floyd's death
okay and that's that's a hard case to
prove did
like why would he why would he think
that that would cause floyd's death
to put him in a neck hold that is a
basic suppression hold again approved by
the minneapolis police department
you have to prove that he intended to do
that that at the very least he was
negligent
in that he knew that what he was doing
could cause somebody's death well
barring
barring floyd's underlying conditions
that really shouldn't cause your death
right if you don't have a serious
cardiopulmonary issue to begin with
plus meth in your blood plus fentanyl in
your blood makes it real difficult so
here's the thing
shelvin could easily be convicted there
is certainly a case for chav to be
convicted on second-degree manslaughter
lines
annie mccarthy has made that case over
at national review but if he is
acquitted that's not because of the
racism of the american system that's
because due process of law
requires a very strong showing of
evidence and prove
but all the media are going to show is
all the inflammatory stuff from the
trial
the media are going to pretend like any
defense of derek shalvin by his own
defense team
is somehow racist in and of itself all
they're going to show is is the
witnesses
to what was obviously
a tragedy at the very least speaking
emotionally about the issue so for
example
one of the witnesses yesterday called
the cops animals on the stand which
raised an objection here's what that
sounded like
when you were watching this interaction
between these three minneapolis
four minneapolis police officers and mr
floyd
were you watching a cage match at the
time well
i only seen two of them the animals so
i was watching more of a humane
show okay objection
that's okay okay okay and uh he he
suggested
that uh he was watching a humane bleep
show humane bleep show
um and uh he said i was not watching a
sport okay that
all this sort of testimony is
provocative but it really is not
probative probative means it doesn't
actually contribute
to whether there is guilt here or not
right it doesn't go to the underlying
fact pattern
but most of the testimony that's gonna
be shown on late night tv and throughout
the day on your 24 hour news networks is
going to be the witnesses
saying that they stayed up nights for
example that was what one of the
witnesses said yesterday
it's been nice i stayed up
apologizing
and apologizing
to george floyd for not doing more and
not physically interacting and
not saving his life but it's like
it's not what i should have done it's
what he should have done
okay so you know obviously this sort of
stuff it would be heart-wrenching it
would be terrifying it would be terrible
but that doesn't go to the probability
of value here but what you're going to
see is the most evocative emotional
testimony you're not going to see any of
the underlying fact pattern presented
on national tv because that might
actually undercut the narrative that
this is a straightforward case with an
easy solution
okay meanwhile speaking of lies that are
being told the the media continued to
simply just
tell lies at this point about a wide
variety
of topics surrounding kovit at 19 so for
example
they continue to trot out the lie that
ron desantis
lied about coveted numbers the people
who are pushing that lie people at the
new york times people at yahoo news
they're completely misreading the study
upon which they are basing their
coverage
alexander nazarian a reporter for yahoo
news is one of the great promulgators
of this he has a piece today it says new
research published earlier this month in
the american journal of public health
argues florida is under counting the
number of people who died from covet 19
by thousands of cases
casting new doubt on claims governor
desantis has navigated the coronavirus
pandemic successfully
so the idea is that some 5 000 people
died of covet and that was not reported
properly
but that is not correct okay that is not
actually right
in fact the the notion that coven 19 is
responsible for all
or most of these excess deaths is in
question
a lot of people died in excess because
they stayed at home for other reasons
they had a heart attack at home for
example in fact the number of excess
deaths
state by state not reported as coveted
is fairly consistent across the state
lauren rossen statistician at the
national center for health statistics at
the centers for disease control and
prevention
whose analyzed excess deaths told yahoo
news she saw nothing exceptionally
suspicious in the state's excess death
numbers
said florida doesn't stand out to me
other critics describe florida as
neither a glowing success nor an
unmitigated disaster
but rather a state that has handled the
pandemic with some successes and some
failures but they are trying to
manufacture a headline
suggesting that ron desantis openly lied
about the numbers of coveted deaths the
way that
andrew cuomo lied about the number of
people who died in nursing homes that
isn't true
that isn't true but the media are
pushing untrue
untruths about kovid throughout they've
been pushing on truths about covert for
a long time and now they're pushing
untruths about the direness of the
situation and the number of number of
people who have died in red states for
example of covet the biden
administration is pushing obvious lies
now
about about the situation regarding
covet the reality of the situation in
the united states
is that kovid is on the wane we all know
that kobe is on the wane
code is on the lane because the
vaccinations are very high and because
it has already burned its way
through most major parts of the united
states i'm looking at the covid numbers
today in the united states
there has not been a significant
escalation in the daily new cases of
covid nationwide
since approximately let's see
february 23rd it's been stable since
then so today there are about 62
000 new cases of cova diagnosed in the
united states at the height
there were something like 266 000
new cases of cova diagnosed like january
300 000 cases diagnosed january 8th
we are at the lowest levels that we that
we've been at of
new cova diagnosis in the united states
since essentially october
okay and by the way the levels of
increase
are completely stagnant there is no
national level of increase it's
increasing in certain areas it is not
increasing nationally
the number of active cases in the united
states has actually been declining
since approximately the middle of
january the end of january according to
worldometers.com
and yet we are being told that we're
still in the middle of a crisis because
the more the biden administration can
push the idea there's a crisis the more
they can push forward spending plans
the more they can push forward all of
their big government rejiggering of the
economy
the more they can push forward the idea
of vaccine passports the thing about
vaccine passports they're relatively
unnecessary when the pandemic is over
you don't need them once the pandemic is
over and these vaccines are so
unbelievably effective i mean they're
miraculously effective they're so
unbelievably effective
that particularly if you've already been
vaccinated you really do not have to
worry at that point as dr marty mccarthy
of johns hopkins university said
once you're a month out from your first
vaccine and two weeks out from your
final vaccine
go about your daily life you're fine
okay meanwhile
the biden administration continues to
push panic that is a lie
again it's it's dishonesty all the way
up and down policy after policy it's
dishonesty the root ideology of the
administration is a lie
the equity lie but it's not just that
why they're telling lies about covet in
order to achieve their purposes they're
telling lies about the border in order
to achieve their purpose
we'll get some more of that in just one
second first when you are running a
business
hr issues can absolutely kill you you
don't tend to think about it when you
start a business why do you
hr like isn't that just that annoying
guy toby from the office like you don't
know anything about hr then you start
running a business and you realize you
can run
really fast into a lot of liability if
you haven't taken care of your hr issues
wrongful termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations
hr manager salaries are not cheap
they're an average of seventy thousand
bucks a year
bambi is spelled b-a-m-b-e-e it was
created specifically for small business
you can get a dedicated hr manager craft
hr policy maintain your compliance all
for just 99 bucks a month
with bamboo you can change hr from your
biggest liability to your biggest
strength
your dedicated hr manager is available
by phone email or real-time chat
from onboarding determinations they
customize your policies to fit your
business
and help you manage your employees
day-to-day all for just 99 bucks a month
month-to-month no hidden fees you can
cancel any time you didn't start your
business because you wanted to spend
time on hr compliance
let bambi help get your free hr audits
today go to bambi.com
shapiro right now to schedule that free
hr audit that is bambi.com
shapiro spelled b-a-m-b-e-e dot com
slash appear get your hr issues taken
care of today it's a must-do
if you are a business owner go to
bambi.com
shapiro today all right we're gonna get
some more on the democratic lies being
told about coveted right now because
they're pretty astonishing we'll get to
that in a second first as you've
probably heard candace owens
joined the daily wear a few weeks ago
with premiere of her brand new talk show
canvas
the show streams on dailywear.com
fridays at 9 pm eastern 8 pm central you
can get the audio podcast canvas
on apple spotify or wherever you listen
to your podcast candace hosts a series
of guests on the show every week making
for lively panel discussions insightful
interviews
candace is a is a hoot her show is a
blast i did it last week but this week's
show was also fantastic featured guests
have included
jacqueline brandon titan john rich me
candace is the first daily wire show to
appear in front of a live audience but
do not worry if you can't attend the
show in person you can tweet your
questions to
the candice show at the canada show for
a chance to have candace
answer your question at the end of her
show so if you need some candid zones in
your podcast feed
look no further head on over to the
apple podcaster spotify subscribe today
be sure to leave a five star review if
you like what you hear
join now so you can tune in friday night
to see
the latest of her hot takes and the
story behind them you're listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in radio show in the nation
[Music]
so the biden lies are not relegated to
the area of race or voting policy
uh they are also just absolutely evident
in pretty much every area of the body
administration policy so for example on
coven
so the reality is that we are on the
wane when it comes to covet and yet we
have rochelle willenski the head of the
csc warning of
the cdc warning of doom doom
now here's the weird thing walensky also
acknowledges that by the way
we are doing a good job vaccinating and
not only are we doing a good job
vaccinating across the country
once you're vaccinated you're done once
you're vaccinated we're not worried
about you carrying the virus
this thing has an extraordinarily high
success rate particularly the pfizer and
moderna
vaccines have like well over a 90
success rate when it comes to preventing
serious disease
and like a 99 success rate in preventing
death
here's walensky saying two things that
make no sense back to back
she said yesterday that their data
suggests the vaccinated don't carry the
virus that's kind of good news
because we were told you have to wear a
mask forever here she was
basically explaining that you don't have
to wear a mask forever once you're
vaccinated
we can kind of almost see the end we're
we're vaccinating so very fast
our data from the cdc today suggests
um you know that that vaccinated people
do not carry the virus don't get sick
um and that it's not just in the
clinical trials but it's also in real
world data
okay so that's good news right um
literally the day before she was warning
of doom
here she was i'm going to reflect on the
recurring
feeling i have of impending doom we have
so much to look forward to what so much
promise and potential of where we are
and so much reason for hope but right
now i'm scared
so i'm speaking today not necessarily as
your cdc director
not only as your cdc director but as a
wife
as a mother as a daughter to ask you to
just please hold on a little while
longer
i so badly want to be done i know you
all so badly want to be done we are just
almost there but not quite yet
okay they just want control she's she's
saying once you're vaccinated you're
good to go and
you've still got your biting out there
being like you wear a mouse guys where
where am i sanji moon angie got mask
individually
here he was a couple of days ago talking
about how it's patriotic to mask
even after vaccinated apparently you
should still keep masking for no reason
at all here is joe biden pushing it each
of us has to do our part we have an
obligation
patriotic obligation wash your hands
stay socially distanced where
a mask is recommended by the cdc
and get vaccinated as i do my part to
accelerate the vaccine distribution of
vaccinations
i need the american people to do their
part as well
mask up mask up it's a patriotic duty
it's the only way we ever
get back to normal okay that was true
like a year ago
now with the vaccines that is not true
okay once you're vaccinated like
you know it'd be useful honest to god
what would be useful is for biden to
take off his mask at this point
he's been vaccinated for him to say
listen you want to get back to regular
life with no mask
take off the mask if you're vaccinated
if you're not vaccinated you should wear
a mask because you can still transmit
the disease
and receive the disease but once you're
vaccinated you're good to go but he's
not doing that
it's all confused messaging out of the
white house in fact biden is now saying
he wants states to reinstate their mass
mandates
okay and those mass mandates are going
to apply to people whether they are
vaccinated or not which again makes no
scientific sense
here was joe biden pushing states to
reinstate mass mandates which by the way
weren't effective in the first place
i'll show you in a second
i'm reiterating my call for every
governor mayor and local leader
to maintain and reinstate the mass
mandate
please this is not politics
reinstate the mandate if you let it down
and business should require mass as well
the failure to take this virus seriously
precisely what got us this mess in the
first place
risk more cases more desks deaths
i mean you don't want to risk more desks
guys desks are very very very dangerous
according to
that guy is not with it hey by the way
remember that time that joe biden
suggested that if you didn't want to
mass mandate it's because you were
neanderthal
so texas got rid of its mass mandate
florida hasn't had a statewide mass
mandate ever
okay and those are not the states where
this stuff is surging
here is a chart from yesterday that
demonstrates the difference between the
so-called neanderthal states and the
science
states right so this would be
mississippi and texas
lifting their masks okay the ones that
are neanderthal thinking
what you have seen is a radical decrease
in new cases diagnosed
per day beginning just a few weeks ago
in fact right after they lifted their
mass mandate look at that
boom it drops and then there are the
science states
michigan new jersey new york they have
statewide mass mandates and um
they've increased their rates so those
mass mandates not useful
now so meanwhile anthony fauci continues
to tell parents their kids shouldn't
play together without mass
this is this has been stupid for a long
time three-year-olds
playing together at the park is not the
risk of covid that is not the risk of
kovid kids have not been spreading this
thing at the same rate as adults
even when kids do spread it apparently
the disease does not have as serious an
impact
as before the goal here is just to
prolong this thing
it's pretty obviously from the biden
administration just to prolong this
thing we are at the very end of this
we all know it the economy is back open
flights are like 90
full at this point we're back into
swinging mode but joe biden wants
another two trillion dollar
infrastructure package and so baby
baby's gotta baby's gotta pay the rent
somehow and the way baby's gonna pay the
rent is by telling you that covet is
never going to end
here's anthony fauci warning parents
about kids playing together without
masks
the children can clearly wind up getting
infected when we talk about what you can
do
when you're vaccinated you can certainly
have
members of a family if the adults are
vaccinated and you're in the home with
your child
you don't need to wear a mask and you
can have physical contact
when the children go out into the
community you want them to continue to
wear masks
when they're interacting with groups
from multiple households
yeah again the the notion that small
children are a vector for transmission
here
is completely unproven at this point
like really really unproven
but again everything's hilarious to the
biden administration truth has no part
of this
kamala harris openly laughs now like
like the the joker laugh is becoming
more and more a dominant part of her
personality
it's very weird and she was discussing
in a speech the other day
parents being unable to send their kids
to school in the middle of the pandemic
and she just started laughing about it i
mean this really is like joaquin phoenix
pathological can't help the laughter
stuff here's kamala harris the vice
president of the united states
apparently suffering from the same
condition as
as joaquin phoenix's joker very weird
stuff
more people are seeing
that yeah affordable child care is a big
deal
more parents are seeing the value of
educators
when they had to bring their kids
and say we're not paying them nearly
enough
[Laughter]
did somebody say something funny like i
i don't i honestly i don't understand
what's going on
what is going on we have a leader of the
free world who is not a sentient human
and his vice president is a person who
breaks into cackling bouts of laughter
for no reason at all
and these are the people you want to
give more power these morons
these people what what why why would you
give them the power to spend trillions
of your dollars those dollars aren't
coming from nowhere they're coming from
you
in the future why would you do that like
what are you doing
this is crazy get a bunch of morons in
charge
like give these people more power they
are telling you lies day after day after
day your media are facilitating those
lies day after day after day the same
people who are saying follow the science
by the way i would be remiss if i didn't
know this okay
the same people in the media who are
saying follow tough science not the
science
tough science tough sciences politics
masquerading and science follow tough
science here is a paragraph from cnn
i'm not i have to read this verbatim you
ready because this is about these these
bills
that prevent biological men from
competing with biological women in
sports
and that's what these bills do here is
cnn
the most trusted name in news with james
earl jones's voice
quote it's not possible to know a
person's gender identity at birth
and there is no consensus criteria for
assigning sex at birth
does that sound like science to you does
it
but what what there is no consensus
criteria for assigning sex at birth
um i can think of a few of them like
consensus criteria
in fact medical professionals do it all
the time in fact small children do it
all the time
believe it or not my four-year-old son
he can with like 98
accuracy identify the sex of the people
he is talking to it's amazing
like either he's clairvoyant or there
are objective identifiers of sex
it's incredible but this is cnn that is
just
that is just dropped right into a story
without even like quoting what experts
say
it's just unreal these are the people
you should trust with the science
they're 100 trustworthy
on every level they're 100 trustworthy
and by the way they're trustworthy on
the border as well
where apparently according to one border
patrol agent we are now at over 700 over
capacity
the the the border is being completely
overridden
and overrun the good news is that our
democratic friends just continue to lie
about it that's exciting stuff
alexander ocasio-cortez said today she
finally commented on the border
situation like she finally did it
and you know what she said she said
quote this is not a surge
these are children and they are not
insurgents
yes that was the take from aoc that it's
not a surge because they're not
insurgents despite the fact that
that doesn't have to do with anything
yep the dishonesty the dishonesty but
definitely trust them definitely trust
these people with your life your future
your family they know better than you
probably should give them more power
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hours of the ben
shapiro show this week michael knowles
will be guest hosting make sure to tune
in in the meantime
go check out his show it is available
right now i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
criminal coyotes flourish ferrying
foreign nationals across our southern
border
republican matt gates considers leaving
congress amid a sex scandal
investigation
and big tech tries to take out steven
crowder check it out
on the michael knowles show